Dakara knock we're here coming to you
live from Europe I'm gonna do a stream
tonight see see what uh who's online I
thought mom was doing a stream earlier
so I feel like I'll try to get stream
now at the same time it's always playing
Chicago a little bit earlier I don't
know if he still is but let's see they
they appear to be playing I'm definitely
gonna try and play one of them and that
goes without saying I won't say once I
stopped playing so let's let's see how
it goes all right so yeah I think I'm I
think I'm online I'm oh I'm online right
Chris yeah yeah yeah okay so see all
right you guys so it looks like I'm
Lionel oh wait to see who wants to play
again okay I see a little lil 91 yeah I
want to place all Pleasant bullet let's
start a little bull let's get this off
to the usual start so I'm gonna play
some kind of normal setup see normal you
know hippo type set up put a bishop on
b7 maybe she'll move the knight if she's
if she's in a deep think probably she's
gonna move the knight I guess not
I'll play g6 there's seven gonna play d6
probably 97 and castles now let's see
let's see what happens castles c5 maybe
h5 here maybe not play knight c6 I'll
take on g6 maybe h6 probably not the
best mood to play age sex because now
after I was six I mean I can kind of
just like I don't know if that six was a
good move but I'm just kind of just play
some moves
d 45 fish page three over k e8 if d4 the
Queen f7 I'm not too worried about d5
it's definitely moved so a for now I'm
gonna take probably night before since
now with a four I can go night before
Bishop g2 of the strange we're gonna
play e5 be careful with this Bishop now
on eh eggs I could get trapped fish
before I'm gonna go for I'm a play off
595 let's play Queenie 7 side stop it
now nice
little bit loose here on g5 tik-tok
Queen d2 I could take I mean I have
night b3 as a threat now so now I'm
gonna go night b3 pick up the rook on a
one or maybe pick up the bishop on c1
actually with this night here on g5 but
now I'll just take they'll take the rook
and Knight e6 work c8 if it takes I
think I can just take on d5 Queen 8/3
not hate c2 to pick up another rook it's
kind of gotten pretty bad for white
Queen e2 I could take the rook I just
don't want to allow any tricks here I'll
go - rough six probably 96 Queen out
seven or something
takes takes now let's see okay
eighty-six takes takes one out of three
all this take the rook or take the
Knights are it takes takes shade it
probably takes Bishop h6 I assume
District seven and I should just done
just up so many pieces here this should
just be winning should be a flag coming
in a second I'll throw this in just to
win on time and that should be
yeah that was not not very good I don't
know if that was laggy or what's going
on yeah I was a bit a little bit slow so
alright so um so I'll pay attention to
the comments as well in the meantime so
what's that so I see dad be on skis says
he looked younger yeah I just decided to
shave so I'm a head of the World Cup
part of the superstition so I'll stop
shaving in a few days and grow out a
beard during the World Cup for as long
as I'm in it hopefully I'll be in it for
a month so we'll see how that goes at
any rate
someone else has to where am i
broadcasting from or streaming from I
should say and right now I'm actually
streaming from from from Athens Greece
I'm here for a couple of days and then
from here I'll go to Tbilisi Georgia so
so yeah so okay so let's see so let's
see so who else is online right now
let's take a look someone asks did I win
any money on Mayweather no I didn't I
didn't actually bet on it I asked a
couple of people I know in Vegas to
maybe put some bets in but by the time
the odds came back I mean it really
wasn't what was it wasn't worth it
so I mean I'd something like I think the
last line that I heard maybe an hour and
a half two hours before was something
like I think was put 500 down to 185
dollars which I mean really it's not
worth it you know considering the fact
that something could go wrong I mean
that's that's not even 20% so so yeah so
let's see so who's on line all right as
being slow let's see I'll reload the
screen page see you see where everyone
is in the meantime keep asking the
questions so yeah so fancy place in
Trump's is minus 375 on Bodog yeah
that's that's about right like yeah I
just didn't see the point of betting on
it at the last minute so anyway alright
so it looks like everyone's playing at
the moment so again as I've said many
times before if anyone don't want to
donate five dollars I'll play of a game
bullet or blitz so if you are interested
go ahead and donate in the meantime
while I wait for a game let's see I mean
I guess I'm on is still playing after
Galka so all the way till they're done
and I'm probably challenged one of them
maybe I'll challenge warned our start at
9 1951 plays some three minute maybe
yakov if he's if he wants to play some
blitz to I don't know if either and we
want to play actually I see ali reza
wants to play bullet but after that last
game where the I don't know this
connection would seem to rather shaky
I'm probably just gonna stick to blitz
for now so let's see so who else is
there Santo blue also I mean I'll
challenge him three minutes if he wants
to play in the meantime keep it going
okay so here we go see ya so I'm playing
Santo blue Santa who is Santa blue I see
a picture that looks like the Turkish is
that yo mas it's one of those Turkish
guys I'm not sure which one ones who was
on the Olympiad team I've seen the
picture but it's not big enough and I'm
not gonna click and go to the page so
I'll I'll just uh I'll wait tell them
until later to figure out who it is so
okay so so far normal probably gonna do
the double fee on keto again see for I
guess he's gonna force me to play c5 and
we're now actually have something
relatively theoretical I have six
probably he'll play d4 here I'll take
all right wants to play d3 so now there
are many ways of playing you know I'm
just gonna play d5 I'll try to play
something interesting at least something
a little bit different than normal so
it's my stream dropping frames that was
someone say that is it is it okay so
maybe it's a bit laggy let me see if it
keeps lagging a bit if it if it doesn't
pick up then I'll probably just stop the
stream to me it's just where I am the
connections not ideal if that's the case
then yeah but hopefully that's not the
case hopefully I'm still here playing
for a bit so a3 work c8 I mean so far
that's a pretty good position that I've
gotten here so Queen 84 I'll play a six
yeah I mean actually I'm not even our
hotel
Airbnb so really if it's not my fault if
the connections bad but yeah I I wanted
to see on a hotel but it's too expensive
here so I just ended up doing Airbnb for
the first time ever I'm pretty happy
with it actually it's been pretty pretty
good so II six so let's let's see so
Bishop g5 I'm gonna play off six
probably Bishop h6 maybe just back to d2
I mean I complete g5 here maybe I know
if I want to I think I'll play something
a little bit simpler 97 with the thread
of Knight a5 attacking the queen of the
Bishop I'm not gonna draw draw many
arrows here said I don't want any vaccin
you know somehow like play like Knight
f5 and just like hang everything so
takes takes again I'm threatening Knight
a5 it's a 95 now here I can take with
the Queen maybe or the bishop pain take
with just about anything I can even play
Knight a5 interestingly nothing I think
I'll play Knight f5 just hit the Queen
on h4 force him to move somewhere
although I just allowed Knight f4 maybe
he missed he actually night at for
attacking e6 with a fork but he didn't
see it so now now I think I'll play I've
got to be careful here I might take with
the Bishop b4 and I've got nothing so
I'm gonna have to take with the pawn now
he's got Bishop h3 which could be kind
of annoying but he doesn't he doesn't
see it so he plays b4 now I'm gonna play
Queen d6 off for Queen trade
so let's it so maybe he'll take or will
they play Queen G to see what he's gonna
do here so he takes on c5 interesting so
I'm gonna take and he's gonna take
obviously I know like he's he obviously
wants to go for bish page three which is
a logical move but I'm not sure it's
it's quite that good since he allowed
his pawn to become doubled here on the
file as well so he's obviously gonna
take on a 500 take night h4 and probably
play King off seven and the game will
continue I'm so ripped b1 I could take
on f3 give him the triplets and I mean I
don't I don't see any reason not to kind
of don't want to but I'll do it I mean I
don't see anything better so I'm gonna
go see four he's obviously gonna take
the knight on a5 now you may be able
player could be something first
he's gonna take now I'm gonna play rook
c5 or take I think I'll just take keep
it simple so he'll take on f5 probably
work d1 maybe rook d7 I'm gonna play
rook da try and push this pawn down to
d3 d2 I mean it's a strange position so
we've got like three on it I mean he's
got triple pawns here I've got double
pawns now I assumed I should go D - and
if Kingi - maybe rook d4 probably just
rook d4 cuz now I've got to check on e8
and the King on e - could be a weak
he plays rook e3 so now I'm gonna go
King off seven now he has notice no
squares on this efile - to play with
this still is very draw mind you so I'm
probably I'm gonna kind of sell in the
position a little bit here try to I'm
gonna push this pawn down to a four
maybe I'm not sure yet if I'm going to
do that I'm gonna play h5 now try try to
slowly improve the position here so work
d5 non-threatening check me - one with
rook rook e7 so he has to retreat play
h4 h 3 now I'm going to go back to d4
King III or no he's gonna play rook b3
now I can take again I can play a four
possible I think I will play
for in fact and and see what I see if I
can't do anything here so I'm gonna
retreat that rook back drop it back now
play for rook East seven maybe please
work III not a moment of truth it's
coming I won't have to start blitzing
very soon
d6 play trick d5
well actually what I want to do sorry is
I want to reset my rook so I'm gonna
reset the rooks on the right squares
which is d5 and d6 and then I'm gonna
try to bring my king over so that's the
first first order of business
no no cleric d4 he may be now worked d5
and he's gotta go kini to again so now
I'm gonna play King d8 and try I want to
get my king over like the B files like
yeah I know if that's realistic or not
so yeah I know I can see seven I'm gonna
go King e6 now if King do one I've rook
b6 I guess so let's see can i maybe
somehow swing my king in so now he's
gonna take obviously or not he's gonna
go that way interesting now probably
hopefully rook be one again
see if I can flag him
because Harry with these three pawns
he's there even if he picks on my off
pawns it's not actually a big deal so
although I kind of have bundled this
very slightly I mean maybe this was the
wrong way to play this let's see what
he's got
so say so
Kings before King before for King b3a -
he's gonna go and I mean yeah this is
obviously a draw but he's I mean I'm
gonna fly him obviously
and yeah alright so that was not not
ideal again it seems like there was
something some flat there's some
something some lag so not not great not
great but you know whatever it's out go
so yeah it can't always have a good
connection everywhere in the world jesus
xe4 I suspect I probably was winning
that if I if I had played that slightly
differently but again I I didn't really
have a whole lot of time and the top
goes my 57 I'll play e5 probably 98 I
assume hopefully rookie 197 imma play
Age 4 night f1 eh 5 standard like Kings
Indian attack style hello here I want to
solidify the center first like make this
this strong long pause chain so c3
probably takes takes so you place b6 now
I want to go night f1 the problem here
relax it's not an e6 looks nice but f6
is very hard to play with this Knight
here and also you can't really put
pressure on the center here like you
can't put pressure on this with this
very long pawn Shane from b2 to e5 so he
plays that so you plays rook c8 now I
can take I think I will take if FG eyes
Bishop h3 so he plays the H gonna go
Bishop age three anyway try to try to
put some pressure along this long
diagonal now so he takes now I have an
interesting decision here I think I'm
going to take and take on d4 I don't
know if it's the best way to play but
now this Bishop on g7 is really hummed
in and this pawn structure can't be
attacked he can't attack this pawn on d4
because he doesn't know a C pawn so I
mean black is still kind of okay here
but there are problems there are some
very serious technical issues here like
I also Knight g5 hitting East six
potentially so Bishop a6 now I think
Knight g5 is in order
yeah ninety five looks like a good move
here so Queen c6 now I'm gonna play off
for to further solidify this
you know this this big center that I
have here just also to avoid any sacks
on on on e5 as well tonight f8 Bishop
before hit this pawn in East 7 so Rick
Dees own plate rook see one probably the
queen b5 I don't know maybe maybe not
but yeah he plays Queen b5 has expected
so it takes takes I'll play Bishop III
here
just keep the bishop safe at home here
on a3 attacking e7 like Queen d2 and now
ok plays rook c7 I could play work c1 I
suppose in fact I don't see a good
reason not to although he does have
queen d3 actually I got a bikini Queen
d3 I can take take Queen d1 and I'm fine
but it's a little bit shaky a little bit
shaky the front here for black the e7 is
also extremely weak long terms so black
black axes has real problems here so
Queen d7 so I'll take click Queen c3
offer an exchange because again that
this pawn in East 7 is so weak that he's
gonna have to keep Queens on the board
and actually now I can maybe just go
clean before even and how does he
protect a pawn in East something so he
plays Bishop h6
so I'll take I'm sure he'll take care
probably Bishop g5 or yeah he does
cleavage 45 I'll take so I'm of upon
here opposite colored bishops black has
decent drawing chances I would say not
not great but decent so he finds an IP
it's no i'ma have to retreat the bishop
all the way back to on c3 to protect d4
but everything's pretty solid here all
my pawns are on dark squares they can't
be attacked by this Bishop so a5 I'll
play he wants to play b5 he wants to
play B 5 B 4 so I mean I'm gonna play b4
now I don't know if they'll take or play
a 4
almost I mean probably objectively this
is close to a draw just because the the
way the pawns are but but you know Never
Say Never
nice I'm open actually 4 I'm gonna go
Knight f6 make the pre move
maybe try to get a Knight to d7 and c5
so whoops I guess I undid that pre move
g5 interesting free pawn I'm gonna take
it you should be too I mean I have the
feeling this this might not be a draw
anymore because chief I've felt very
wrong like I thought Blackwood her just
sat back and waited
where's now there are some issues here
Bishop c2 I'm gonna play okay so he's
threatening to take on g5 right so I'm
gonna play 98 threatened 97 attacking
both these pawns here so 97
so there's about five I'll take the pawn
now I've got this pants beep on that can
run down the board so I should be
winning here I'll play 96 and again this
beef Han is just going right down the
board in a hurry so there should be six
I'll play b5 and probably this is just
already just lost because now I'm gonna
go fish up c7 and I'm just gonna squirt
the pawn right to be aid and to make
matters worse for black also my pawns
are on dark square so he this Bishop is
basically useless Bishop p.m. Bishop
here cannot attack any of my pawns so he
resigns um okay let's see knocks can be
four hopefully I'll stick to I'll stick
to the pattern just playing planks
playing stuff so this would be three e6
see what he wants to do it so Queen e2
I'll play g6 9 f3 or okay please c3 I'll
play Bishop g7 I have 397 probably he'll
Castle d6 pretty standard just gonna go
h6 g5 probably like I always doing this
this this line there's a four I'll play
a six just to stop him from getting this
pawn to 85 and 86
oh good g5 I have one open a g6 if he
goes Knight g3 me go g4 so it's a little
bit so he does go Knight g3 so I'm gonna
go g4 92 I can play Knight f4
maybe I'll just play 92 h5 probably just
try to try to you know put pressure on
this night on g3 so 94 I play h4 he
probably is Knight f5 so I've got to be
a little bit careful so I think I'll
play something I think I'll just play
Knight d7 well I'll give him Knight a5
if he really wants it here I mean but
I'm bringing my knight closer to the to
the play so more into the game at least
so let's see what he wants to do here
so again if you guys have questions keep
them coming I'll be here for a while
definitely gonna play play for quite a
bit tonight that's my plan at least
since this is gonna be my last stream
for quite a while hopefully assuming
that I do well in the world cup so
Bishop c2 I will if I play h4 is he
really gonna go Knight a5 he doesn't
have to go Knight f5 so I'm I'm gonna
play Queen e7 just develop put the Queen
here maybe maybe it maybe give myself
castles idea of something like that
seems like a reasonable try it anyway so
so we'll see what he wants to do so yeah
alright Bishop d2 snow I mean I really
want to play H 4 H 2 right now but I who
cares I'm just gonna go for it even if
it's probably bad I'm going to go for it
so it's gonna go G sir I'm gonna go
Knight f6 now e4 is weak also so you
have the e5 here maybe then Bishop f3 or
actually 5 ITA I forgot that Bishop
takes chief 6 here but Bishop g6 maybe I
Bishop f3
ok so he just he just takes but actually
97 now honking g6 hmm ok this this might
not turn out very well so he's gonna
take on g6 obviously or no he's gonna
take on g4 what what am I missing
so I just take and they take c5 and I
have Knight f3 was with the discovery on
everything I mean I could be missing
something here but I don't feel like I
am I feel like maybe just missed Knight
f3 take c1 because everything is just
kind of falling I mean this is just like
I mean everything so he plays rook e5
but now I just take and I'm just up up a
clean exchange here it's officially for
castles would be a bad move that would
give him everything he wants f5 Queen g6
I mean I guess I can place c5 or c6 c5
looks like the right move just to
protect the bishop with the Queen
see six was also probably fine but I
kind of want to keep this long diagonal
open this dis h18 diagonal
rather than close at night does play he
plays a five I think I might just Castle
yeah why not just cancel get the King
out of the center now I'm threatening
out five as well like there all kinds of
threats so and if he takes I just take
back and then I'm threatening Nate on g2
so let's let's see what he wants to do
so so
[Music]
so anyway again I don't see many
questions I guess everyone's just
watching alright so he played rookie one
I kind of had to pay attention to the
game on so if I play b5 that some mover
creates a move
I think b5 makes sense just again I'm
threatening I'll just take with the
Queen and meet him on g2 so he plays
Queen f3 now I'll just do I play Bishop
v8 is Bishop g5 actually a threat or
maybe it's all clubs play op 6 protect
the bishop solidify it here in the Sun
or no no now I can't do anything against
and probably next time I'm gonna take on
e4 and play like Queen B sub and I think
I'll just play this even though I'm
giving up this pawn here on c5 yeah I
feel like it's more important just to
get Queens off the board and I this pawn
an h3 which is very valuable because he
could have big problems in this iDEN
game a long-term well let's play Bishop
d6 probably he'll take if Bishop d4 oh
just play e5 and he's gonna have
problems because if he takes takes takes
I've rook e8 like be 5 rook e8 is a big
problem and now I'm Bishop e3 I'm gonna
play like rook f8 and this is this is
getting pretty ugly in a hurry so let's
let's see what he's gonna do
actually you know I'm just looking at
this picture now I'm realizing is this
guy Turkish where's this guy India and I
think I played this guy in the world
blitz in rapid if I'm not mistaken um I
feel like I played this guy actually
they're like the face is coming back to
me now so rookie to this just wanders
work f2 and Bishop c5 and it's just like
all over so ok this is a next game I'll
play b3 which would be to see what he
wants to do g3 I'll play Bishop g2
probably I'm just gonna play the same
kind of side of III 92 or e3 d3 one
other two probably d3 then I'm gonna
play 92 probably little castle fish be
sick so he's gonna play with Queen d7
probably or h5 yeah so H through it
because now if you please H 4 then I
have G 4 a 5 I'll play a 4 no no I mean
it's a question-- b4 and c4 like which
square is more useful because now also I
can go Knight c3 and Knight d5 because
with this point 85 never as a 6 to kick
the night so I go that's really nice
outpost here on b5 so he plays rook d8
95 obviously wants to put the bishop on
b8 no no I have a choice I can play
Bishop e3 I can also just I mean c4 is
too extravagant I think I'll just play
Knight f3 now maybe put a knight on
chief I was again he's he's put his
pawns on a 5 and H prices opened up
these b5 and it's g5 square so so we'll
see um all right did I miss something
don't hear anything
no I'm sorry I'm sorry let's see okay so
okay so alright so it plays d4 so Knight
g5 I can play Knight e5 I can play e4
Knight g5 d off the e4 might be a slight
problem I don't really want to play you
for it but I don't think I really have a
choice I'm going to do it because now I
also get c4 so I mean black has really
put his pawns these on some squares that
are not desirable here so night h7 now
open 82 attacked upon in h5 i mean vs i
want to route this Knight to c4 so now i
please h4 obligee for this isn't really
what I was hoping for but night night f8
I could play a foreign gamble you know I
know let's not let's have some fun I
don't want some blocked it's a block
position where there isn't much play so
I'm gonna try and make this interesting
so I'll play Knight f3 castle
I mean I guess he his Bishop takes chief
or maybe I just realized he's got
something like that but anyway he
doesn't do it he does something else he
plays 95 no Bischoff one or not Bischoff
one sorry bishop see one I'm gonna try
and put pressure on this for pawn so
he's probably gonna take I would assume
again if Bishop g4 now though I have
Knight takes e5 so as long as I as long
as I'm careful about any sacks over here
you know I'm chief worry sure I should
be doing okay so so so let's see so
maybe he'll play he'll play night chief
okay so he does go to a chief or so I
have to take obviously now I don't
really know because if he takes on chief
or I can probably just put my King on h2
I mean obviously he's got this long
diagonal here he's got this long
diagonal dat h2 which should begin if
you never push a pawn he's in great
shape but I'm not sure I ever can so
it's it's not completely clear so he
plays Knight h4 I guess who wants to go
night she to maybe or something I don't
I don't know what his ideas but I'm just
gonna play e5 trying to try and close
close the diag and I'll make this I
didn't mess here if I can I mean I think
blacks probably okay blacks probably
doing quite well here but I'm not sure
I'm not sure about that so I can play
east six just like Queen e2 even our
Queen e1 maybe yeah I think I'll just
play Queen e2 here Queen e1 might have
made more sense just to get out of this
this pin on the you know here on G 42
but no I'm gonna activate my bishop put
it on e3 try to do something along this
diagonal I've got to be very active no
like I guess I could take on d4 possibly
yeah why not I don't know if it's any
good but it doesn't doesn't look bad I
know I've got this nice pin
and now when he moves the King I can
move my knight okay so he takes uh his
Bishop takes e5 oh this could be pretty
bad actually cuz I'm gonna this could be
really bad I'm gonna have to play d4 try
to cut the bishops scope off he's gonna
move the bishop probably like c7 or
something and oh he just wants to take
okay now all this take and to play I
don't know maybe rook to d1 takes takes
if g4 I've worked d8 if he doesn't play
g4 I just take oh wait if I take his
Knight a5 so I'm gonna go Bishop c1 so
that you can't he can't push now cuz out
for is hanging I have five I'm gonna
play rook d5 and now now he's got
problems this boat because all his
pieces are slightly i mean his his night
and pawns don't coordinate very well and
you know the Knights so so Brooke f6 but
not about this would be to its a 94 I
guess 94 I can probably just okay so
please okay well she's gonna okay I'm
just taking the night oh that was very
stupid of me but anyway let's see what
happens so five I'll play this 'if I've
probably night off seven I assume I mean
I his pawns are on dark squares so
that's one big Trump I have here I'll
take on p6 probably g4 okay so he's
trying to just run his King as close as
he can to stop me from queening my a
pawn but I think this should just be
winning I mean I feel like this has to
be winning 96 King g5 f3
I can take and go King g3 maybe I don't
know if this works kini 14 f2 and yeah
I'm keying out for I'm gonna sack on I
can sack on f3 I think and now they're
just just pawn just run straight up the
board so
alright alright you guys so let me know
if so guys have any any questions or if
the if there any issues with the stream
just let me know obviously I'll try to
correct them and all this so okay so
night seats around a place see five
probably hopefully d4g three okay so
we're gonna have some kind of repeat of
the last game probably castles night of
six
maybe he'll play d4 maybe I'll play d3
again I'm not not sure he plays d3 d5
probably takes takes I expect Bishop e2
or I wants to take okay now I can take
both ways I'm just gonna take with the
Queen here Bishop e3 I'll just castle
and maybe he'll play rook d8 or he's
just gonna play d4 now I can take I can
take everything and make a very very
very very boring draw can I try to play
on for a win somehow I don't like rook
d8 dc5 Bishop b2 possible not ideal but
possible night a6 also is a move I think
I'll play 96 I'll try to spice it up I
mean see before vision b4 b4 Queen d4
just I mean just a very boring draw
someone try and spice it up a little bit
here probably it's not gonna work out
very well for me but why not
so d c5 now I think I want to play
Bishop takes b2 here but if I take on b2
then takes takes rook d1 bish eight -
that looks very wrong somehow so I'll
just take on c5 let him exchange Queens
probably help them take on c5 I would
assume maybe not those rear cuff d1 I'll
play rook 88 just to get get the rock
off this h1 a diagonal
now I've also got this diagonal too so
he's got some issues here but we'll see
what happens all right so a room two key
writes audio and video quality is good
that's that's very good to hear actually
because again as most people as I've
already mentioned a few times on this
stream I'm not actually at home so there
is a chance of quality could could be
bad so all right so I play ninety four
because I want to take away he wanted an
exchange of play knight c6 I don't want
it to play knight c6 but now do I
actually care that much I don't think so
I'm gonna play e6 support the Bishop on
d5 now here he plays age four I'm gonna
play age five
pretty-pretty even position so oh our
donations not showing up on my on my on
[Music]
my stream
alright you guys let me know if actually
the donations aren't showing up on my
stream I'll try it I'll try to fix I
might take a short break and see if I
can figure that out cuz yeah I know I'm
not hearing anything at all in regards
to donation so okay so donations are not
showing up so okay um alright give me a
UH I think after this game I'll take a
short break and see what's going on as
far as why that is sorry about that you
guys so I've kind of messed up the game
in the meantime - I've I've really made
a mess out of this now it's with I've
made all my pieces very very passive for
absolutely no good reason so see what I
can do here so I'm gonna play 97
probably rookie a tricky 896 maybe I
don't know if I I mean I've really made
a mess out of this like a very serious
mess I'm gonna have to come with some
swindle some some swindle magic here so
okay 796 this would be 5 f6 I mean he's
gonna win a pawn not way to but that way
he's gonna have a bad Bishop again it's
a good night if he plays it so that's
kind of what I'm hoping he'll do but
yeah I wasn't expecting him to do that
cuz the two bishops here are so nice so
works at 7:00 I'm gonna play e5 if he
wants to take I'll take out 4 and hope
he loses the bishop probably I'll play
Knight d4 b4 I'm not sure which one yet
so he does take interesting so it takes
no not-not-not all not all is lost
because he takes I can take on g3 but
I'm gonna play Bishop c5 not all is lost
now I mean I suspect that I should have
some drawing chances here it's not just
hit this is a draw but there should be
some drawing chance
especially with the fact that it's
opposite color bishops too so I'm gonna
play bish me one I'm gonna try to avoid
forcing the rook exchange as long as I
can just to keep open the chance of
maybe you know winning on time or
something like that I actually wrote d4
there which I'm s but now I'm
threatening Bishop g3
now hopefully work before hitting the
two pawns probably work a3 yeah it's a
good move off the Bishop a5 I assume
he'll take on aged 14 G for work d2 is
pretty good
now I'm no I'm hitting the pawn and the
bishop again so now I definitely
shouldn't lose this game whether I can
flag there's another question but but
we'll see we'll see we'll see what I can
do here so King takes h4 play rook up to
King g3 I want to go like bishop eat one
or something actually bishop e 1 or K 1
was a bit of an issue so so Brooke d3
I'll check him they work up to I want to
play like Bishop d2 if I can get it
maybe I'm not gonna get it back no I'm
just gonna have to try and flag him
again very unfortunate and again no no I
just actually just threw it all away for
no good reason
so let's see if I can somehow
see if I can somehow f6 but I got 200
he's got Chuck shoot and now yeah
unfortunately yeah it's too little
unfortunately so yeah yeah that was
unfortunate um yeah actually just made a
draw could have just exchanged the rooks
trying to trying to went on time it
happens okay so what to do what to do
okay
Bishop to c5 I'll castle oh right I
think I said I would stop after this
yeah okay well let me play three more
and then I'll get back over 29 and then
I'll just stall figure out what's going
on here because really they're they
should be showing up I don't know why
they are the donations that is have to
figure that out there should be seven
I'll just take and play 95 so 95 city
wants d6 play Knight d2 maybe play for
a4 do something over here on the UH on
the kingside if I could get the
opportunity and I'm just gonna play g3
wish me sick okay off for probably takes
takes Bishop h4 maybe something like
that on this f6 that looks weird I can
play a five yeah I think I'll just play
off five now takes takes
there should be two work b1 probably
this would be for king h1 and let's see
so the eight now I play Knight f3 cuz I
really want to put something on a G file
and made him so Knight f3 probably
bitched about six now why not play D
Forex 97 I'll just retreat with the
bishop and also this Bishop is really
good too like it's about this really
nice diagonal so King g8 King h8 sorry I
think I'll just play c3 here see what
what he wants to do maybe like night
Queenie seven twenty seven dollars for
like Queen d3 and play like rookie rook
rook e1 and try to push ePHI v65 f6 on
some combination of these two I'll see
what he wants to do so Ricky eight I'll
play rook e1
Queen d7 I'm gonna play rook g1 here
it's time to start putting crusher over
here on the on you know this g7 h6 if I
can not that not that I can't but I'm
sure gonna try at least
so please Knight a5 now he wants really
wants place seasick so I can play e5
here and II five actually looks pretty
good I think
and once unless I'm missing something
which I don't seem to be so takes takes
now working with his Bishop Bishop e7 is
gonna allow yz6 or f6 Bishop g5 I can
maybe just sack the rook on g5 because
it please c6 I'm just gonna take he's
gonna take on d5 I assume I'll take with
Chuck King g8 probably I'll play Queen
I'll take and I'll play Knight e5 or f6
95f 697 rook e1 e1 came to some Chuck
King Chuck
King rookie Rookie rook c7 looks pretty
good I don't know if it's winning but I
might as well try it so he's gonna have
to play off six here and actually f6 97
work you want I can just take because
it's rook will be under attack on b8
it's a 97 probably rook e1 rook e1 rook
da trick e7 and I think he's just busted
completely here so see it rookie 7 and
now I guess he has rook c6 maybe but I
think I can now gonna like Knight f89
defeats one move but actually he's not
threatening anything and his Knight is
kind of boxed out so I could play Knight
f8 I could also just play like King g2
King g3 but nicely forking out no I
don't really like it so no play Knight
Fe
and I figured somehow I've got to be
winning if I can make his pieces passive
then I mean like 96 96 hopefully like
rook d7 and now I can take I don't know
though I somehow this has gotten here
it's only night of four tacked upon now
I've got two to two squares to on to me
made him from d5 and h5 not sure you can
cover them both and ninety tribes in
port because at night eh five will also
control the pollen on on night aged five
also controls the pond so now he applies
work c6 I have rook e8 and the knight
Knight controls the pawn and it's just
it's meeting - so all right let's see
play something different this time like
Knight b6 d6 playing Ali akan something
something more off the beaten path this
game so Bishop d3 I'll play g6 probably
take stakes or castles Bishop g7 it's a
tricky one on this castle pitch three
open I see six
now probably he'll take on d6 I mean or
I'll place c3
okay please Knight c3 but now I can take
and good night before I think or Knight
d4 also but I like night before just
playing to exchange pieces here because
this is an alley I can I am slightly
cramped here if I've got a little bit
less space and white does so I'll play
Bishop a5 probably he'll take I'll take
who is a santoku life I mean I know I've
played this guy before maybe I'll just
be maybe I'll click his profile and take
a look in a second so rook t2i Bishop h6
I've got Knight c4 also which is really
nice but I'm just gonna play work d8
keep it simple play e6 create a weakness
here now you hung upon ER he did not
know he's he's he's he's playing well so
if I take he takes Knights to work c1
traps a knight so that's a nice trick so
I'll play a knight c6 try to put
pressure on spawning e5 now maybe he'll
take on d8 I doubt it I think he'll play
rookie two and I'll play a six fix this
pawn here so I mean now this pawn is
under big big project on e5 so I also
see Foursquare I mean it's just like
everything's ganging up around this pawn
on e5 so so he plays b3 now I can play
each six maybe I kicked the bishop way I
think I will create a creative square
for my king force the bishop one Square
back here to h4 now plays Bishop h4 and
I think here I'm gonna play if I play 94
takes us Bishop e7 or q1 Bishop c5 not
crazy about i'm gonna play Knight e5 so
takes takes probably cc4 I have 95 rook
e1 also a reasonable move I could play a
5 I'm gonna play b5 just for about c4
rookie three so he wants to go rook c3 I
guess I'll play rook c8 I think here
just protect this pawn here just that
rook c3 is not actually a threat and now
I can maybe bring the King over at rook
c3 I thought he couldn't do this don't I
just take yeah I thought he just
couldn't do this I'll take I mean unless
he wants a sack but no if set takes
takes rook to e3 King yourself Bishop f6
tricky one King H to work g8
everything's covered so Brooke c6 won't
play Bishop d6 now the bishop is really
nice here on d6 I've got the rook in
front that controls everything along the
D file it's a work a six I'll play rook
d2
now here he can take a seven if he wants
to I'm not sure he will
I suspect he he won't take a seven but
he might so please see it through so now
I'm gonna go Bishop c5 try to put
pressure on f2 now the rook on d2 is
fantastic this rook is out of play if I
can ever get a Bishop to b6 and just
boxing his rook then I'm doing really
wild work c6 I could take 8/3 but I
don't know if I like it so I'm just
gonna play Bishop d6 b6 sorry
now c4 I'll probably just take now let's
see for our girls and just play no see
for work d4 Bishop f6 is a problem so c4
I'll just take a simple take with the
rook but he takes with the pawn and now
I have worked these sex and now I'm
doing just fantastically well because
now his rook is trap he's gonna he's
gonna have to take on d6 once he takes
on d6 then now c4 is weak Bishop on h4
is weak everything's kind of weak here
now I think just d5 and and now I've
just got a winning completely winning
position so all right so I'll play one
more and then I will take a break and
try to figure out what exactly is going
wrong with the donations as far as why
I'm not seeing them on D stream so I'm
gonna play I'm gonna play the same kind
of JUCO something a little bit different
castles d3 see what he wants to do
probably will play a six again like you
did last night I suspect you well to
play h6 which page for me summon I'm
gonna play Bishop g3 this time now I'm
gonna play Knight d2 something very
unusual this time let's see how he
handles it
place 94 as expected I'm just gonna play
a three create a square for my bishop in
case please b5 c5 now I'm gonna go 95
and and and now basically I want to put
a pond on c3 and kick this night here on
d4 if I can get that than I'm very very
happy so Bishop e6 um now this is
interesting
no I could place c3 yeah I think I will
place c3 force him to go knight c6 now
I'm just gonna play like a simple chess
rook e1 maybe a four maybe not I'm not
maybe knight of 193 also yeah I like
this night off one night III just to
just to just to use this key keep this
night on this very beautiful d5 square
now maybe I Bishop h4 at the right
moment also or or f4 I mean I'm
basically I'm playing for a few things
I'm playing for f4 be for a for fish
page for something in this or d4
possibly 2 but he plays 97 now here I
could do many things I think I'm just
gonna play b4 try to create some
weaknesses over here on the queenside
now in the meantime
Queen b8 now that's a weird I don't
understand that
so no clear work b1 maybe do something
along the B file prevent this a5 idea
Queenie Sutton okay I don't understand
that at all just gonna play I'll play
prophylactic f3 maybe Bishop f2 maybe I
can put the bishop on this long diagonal
so please work see it I'll play push
buff too
and now something along this long
diagonally please f5 but I think I can
just take and now if it plays Queen c5 I
play Knight c2 and it's game over
because queen is trapped or night c4 so
he plays 95 who realizes the error so
now I've got some choice I've got d4
which is interesting I don't know if d4
is the best d4 Knight d4 looks really
attractive but I'm just gonna keep it
simple I'm just gonna take the pawn on
d5 or fb8 now I can play a four I think
I will play a four in fact and now it's
looking just really really good I'm just
up a clean pawn here I've got d4 coming
next move everything is working out very
nicely in the scan so Queen d7 996 here
to pick up the exchange I think it makes
not so work b6 hopefully Bishop takes
the e6 because of rook p6 rook b6 and I
hang this bishop here on e to swing he
takes a knight I take as bishop first
so it does take I take the bishop on e6
now I can't protect his work at the
Queen because on this this rook on c8
will hang well you lose Queen c7 I trade
rooks and then his work on CA is hanging
so it takes I take and now I'm up in
exchange and oh and a pawn as well so
this is a network b5 just to cut up cut
him off now he doesn't know you can't
win this pawn in a four here cuz this
rook just completely cuts off that's
right on e4 and now I resigned so okay
you guys so let's see so I think I'm
gonna see let me let me talk let me ask
a couple people see what's going on as
far as what's with what the deal is with
the donations um let's try to figure
this out
okay so let's say so
[Music]
all right so it's what's going on
yes I don't know what's going on exactly
you guys um yeah let me so someone says
open up my stream Labs okay I'll check
that out that's first thing obviously
you see what's going on see if it works
now maybe
pretty sure should be showing
just see okay so so yeah so why is it
not showing yeah you guys are absolutely
right um so it's it's not showing that's
very weird okay not sure why it's not
showing but all right actually since I
am on stream labs and I do see two
actual challenges so bjh okay I'll send
you a message on so let's let's see um
so first things first I'm gonna play you
guys first thanks for the donations to
be be Handelman that's the first one
okay let me let me find your name up
I'll give you a game now BJ can't ever
be handled I'm sorry you tell me if you
want to play blitz or bullet or what
what you want to play that's it's up to
you
so let's see let me find you all right
so let's see what seems to be the issue
all right so let's see so d Handelman
why is it not showing not actually
seeing you online for some reason um why
am I not seeing be handling online why
am I not saying let me reload the page
so be handling the oh there you are okay
sorry okay there we go okay um
there we go okay 300 shunt okay so it's
okay so I'll start with D for all I'll
play a semi real opening this time
around to give B Handelman at least some
experience I think it's important you
know if I'm just playing normal blitz
generally I'll mix it up I'll play some
role openings sometimes I'll just play
this hippo stuff every game but you know
if I if someone donates and they're not
they're not exactly a super strong
player it's much better to try and play
something reasonably normal to so they
gain something from the game it's not
just simply something where I just make
random moves to you know win so so at
least try to do something so 96 a little
bit unusual but it's a move so I'll play
g3 castle up with Bishop g2 at some
point it's probably gonna happen he
probably should exchange I'm trying to
give him a chance to exchange an idea so
he can play something a bit more normal
in the meantime the other person who
donated was Shaun symp
what's your Shaun stamp what is your
what is your what's your name on chess
calm so t5 okay so this is interesting
so d5 interesting so I'll play a3 now
probably he'll take and I'll prehnite B
takes d2 so so G dog 16 rights B
Handelman is in the military and is
married well if that is the case well
first of all thank you for your service
to our country you do do a great job
protecting us and so we all appreciate
it greatly
so Queen c2 now maybe he'll take nor
normally you play Bishop before in this
this BOGO Indian you want exchange on d2
but so far so far P handle is playing
pretty well so take stinks he's got two
bishops here he's got to figure out how
to develop this just do this queen side
though that's the big issue here for
blocking the position so it plays b6 but
unfortunately now I can take on d5 and
on Queen d5v d5 and fortunately I just
drops the knight on c6
so queen c6 Bishop r5 95
so let's it so maybe Bishop e6 is a move
Bishop g5 it's very hard basically the
problem for for black on I go back to
this position of Nike tutors he needs to
develop these piece and it's very hard
so he takes on c4 he opens up this long
diagonal from Bishop and so probably
it's already a little bit worse or black
at that point but but now I mean now
it's just a it's just a clean clean
piece so it's just a matter of finishing
the game so I'm just gonna exchange the
tritation age of Queens here since I'm
up a whole piece which II six all trade
Queens the knight c6 got a knight to
this really nice c6 square maybe rook d6
plays riff d6 I'll play rook c1 tried it
throughout 94 hitting this Bishop and
rook
so it's pretty hard so f5 good move
stops stops me from playing ie4 so age
for there eh I'm gonna play Knight to c4
now maybe he'll exchange maybe he'll
move the rook but again just trying to
exchange pieces here because I am up up
at night
d 795 it was probably only 36 I'm
guessing it's the only square where it's
still safe where he's not going to drop
it drop it to something in 87 I'm gonna
play rook takes the Saba next move
so yeah
so work up da I'm gonna play d5 try to
try to try to make him move the bishop
on this diagonal maybe so that I can get
a nice Chuck mate so I'm gonna take and
actually now is just like getting mated
brutally on a seven so so yeah that was
not that was a tough game but but
basically in the opening is basically
was supposed to it's when you check on
before you're always supposed to
exchange the bishops on on d2 it's
important so so anyway
all right um so again thank you for the
donation be Handelman so let's say 650
USCF okay so here he is I'll play him
now since I don't know why the donations
aren't showing up it's really kind of
annoying but I'll make do of it for now
I'll sort it out before my next dream
it's a d4 Knight of 6 let's see 5 play
something maybe a bank oh maybe a
bloomenfeld something I play e6 no I'll
just play I'll play easy so I'll just
play Benoni herb Blumenthal one or the
other he plays Knight c3 or Knight f3
please 93 it'll be a vanilla if a please
and I have three I'm gonna go b5 make it
a bloomenfeld so Knight c3 takes you
should play CD 5 so it plays Knight d5
I'll just I'll just trade nights
so I don't know is this shrimp freezing
I saw someone mentioned mentioned the
stream is freezing I don't know it's
that correct or not I mean I it seems to
seem slightly lag even on my own but I
could be could be imagining it
it's alright so I see I guess sis I
think that was who it was maybe maybe
I'm wrong maybe yeah s kiss s kiss kiss
thank you for the donation you're next
in the queue so I see there's something
some of the heavy hitters are back I see
like Dulles is playing bullet now so I
guess he's back I played him the last
night did a stream so yeah let's let's
see so anyway alright so right so Bishop
e2 I'll just play 97 maybe Knight f6 or
vishwas I think I'll put the bishop on
off sex try to keep it some somewhat
similar to real benoni try to do
something on this long diagonal so that
he can't develop this Bishop and if you
can't play Bishop b2 cos to be to pawn
Hanks he's gonna have some trouble
developing let's bischmann this rook
here on the clean side
so rook b1 I'm gonna play 95 offer more
exchanges so yeah sorry you guys that
there are some issues with the stream on
its yeah unfortunately I mean I am here
in Athens Greece I am yeah I'm at an
Airbnb so the connection is gonna be as
good as it's gonna be for the most part
it's been fine but I mean maybe because
I'm streaming it's just a slight issue
but such is life if you guys are okay
with it then all then I'll keep keep
keep continuing so are can ask a
question how do you rate chance against
Fabiano and the speed shush um actually
I didn't know I I didn't know I was
playing him knocks I haven't been
falling super closely because the match
that I played was I want to say already
like in June maybe I want it was at
least like a month month and a half ago
so I haven't been falling super closely
so I read the article on the the Napo
Aronian match which was pretty close but
I haven't general I haven't been
following because I've been getting
ready for the World Cup I've been
traveling and I think they have like two
or three matches in the last couple of
days so I just haven't been following
that closely it's official be - I'll
take the rook probably he'll - I'll take
the bishop I'll take the knight I'm just
gonna exchange try to exchange I have an
extra rook for his Bishop so when you
have an extra when you have extra
material generally you want to try and
exchange and also I have to work so I
need to open up the open up open up
files for my rocks
so I see someone says Fabiano beat up on
Yifan pretty badly yeah I mean I think
of the opening matches the only ones
that were probably the only one that I
think was really close borrowing some
huge upset and I'm the all against Jean
was it's probably not enough against
Aronian that's the only one where I
think it was it was very very evenly
matched all the other all the other
matches there there was a big big big
discrepancy between the two players so
I'll take he'll take I'll play work da
probably hopefully d6 go for the back
rancor or at least he should he had d6
and playing for d7 and but but I would
have played rook c6 and it's still
losing but now I'm gonna try to open up
the C file for my rook I could take with
the pawn I'll take with the rook here h3
now I'm just gonna play qi6 create a
square for my King here so so that d6 is
never possible and now I know I'm just
gonna clean up this ape clean and clean
up the Queen side to take this a pawn
and then just try and run this the a and
the B pawns down the board
b3 probably Bishop c4 any resigns so
alright so oh right sorry of course I
forgot yeah his chess pages mentioned
Gary so is very close yeah I thought
that act was very true yeah I completely
forgot about that match yeah that was
actually the closest match by Forex I
think back him down to the may be the
very last game I feel like Curie was up
when I was eat then he lost last two
games so yeah that was that was very
close of course but yeah so alright so
who's up next it's s kiss s kiss getting
tongue-tied here as gifts gifts if you
could just in the chat maybe message
what your what your name is so that I
can challenge you
and clone clone p @ p WN thank you for
the donation as well again I'm sorry
that it's not showing up here on my
screen I mean oh oh I'll figure it out
but I do have the other window open so I
am actually seeing when the donations
come in I'll give you guys all all shout
out as well as a game so alright so ass
guess alright challenge sent
so okay so I'll play d4 again try to
play something
semi-normal semi standard at least so if
there's something to be taken away from
this game so c6 will play Knight c3 no
six I'm just gonna take plan exchange
Slav this this generally is pretty
pretty pretty boring pretty dry I mean
you're supposed to take the pawn
normally although I myself am NOT one to
talk since I have played Knight takes d5
before sometimes I get annoyed if I play
a slob and someone wants to play boring
exchange like CD five it's like what's
the point you know this is Amelie and
blitz try to win but see yeah so I've
done ninety five as well it's of course
not the correct move but sometimes
sometimes it works
g-dog asks what flag is that that looks
like the switzerland flag that is in
fact the swiss flag switzerland is a
great place also another one of the
countries that I really really like here
in I Europe just a fantastic place I
really love playing in Zurich every year
and Zurich Geneva a lot a lot of even
the small towns are pretty common also
it's just one of my favourite countries
here in Europe the Gangstar 12 says naka
you shave why you shaved the beard yeah
I decided to shave the beard because the
World Cup is coming up and I I'm not I'm
not tremendously superstitious but at
times there are certain things that I do
and one of them is uh I feel like before
a turn that's like knockout you know
it's a little bit kind of like the
playoffs I think and in major sports and
I figure I'm gonna you know shave the
day before they've out starts and then
just grow out to hold on so hopefully
after 30 days I'll have a full beard and
I'll look like a monitor you know
someone like that you know some kind of
uh some kind of uh some kind of
lumberjack
it's a knight c6 I'm gonna sack I'm
gonna go for the this
Jake's age seven sack he's gotta take
he's got except again but I assume this
is winning I haven't actually calculated
this out to to mate or anything but it
looks pretty pretty bad for her for
blacks are so qing-ge h5 threatening me
it on h7 if he takes I'll take with the
H pawn and then I'm threatening made on
the 88 or h7 so so alright so he took so
I take with the pawn no no I mean I'm
threatening me and on each sudden h8 the
only way to really stop it is to push
the off pawn but I think he's just it's
just gonna be checkmate if he goes
between e85 chat I played b4 and then
I'm attacking the Queen I'm still
threatening mate on each 7 h8 and if he
moves the off pawn I'm just gonna go g6
so I go g6 and now like now h7h here
mate and he can't get out this pawn just
covers this f7 Square and there's
there's no breathing room for the black
King here so he got in is checked the
one check at least one of three shocks
so I played before and now it's just
just made in a made in a couple moves
so alright so rocking Eagles let's play
some ball cloud yeah I mean if you guys
if someone wants to make a donation all
I'll play the ball cloud a couple of
games so I'll do that after I play a
clone clone pawn if you could just right
you're right the the the name in the air
he actually moved if you could write the
the name in the chat so I could it's
like that I can find you and play you
and yeah all right so okay so in the
meantime while I wait let's see who else
is online
I feel like there are some there were
some strong players they I feel like we
were coming online here
so Bortnick is online maybe all I mean I
don't think I've played for it and I
call my streams so let's see if he wants
to play some challenge up at three
minutes even wants to play I'm not sure
if he wants to but but we'll see it
anyway so
so play chess brah I assume that means
I'm on I really want to play Bortnick if
he's if he's actually gonna play cuz I I
haven't played him I like playing
someone different on the stream um
but if he's not a runner I maybe I'll
just play this at this Iranian can ELISA
Perugia I guess I think he's a GM now he
must be must be a GM surely um quite
talented young kid I think is like 16 15
16 now Iran seems to be producing some
pretty pretty good kids these days some
because some strong junior players so
they seem to have a very bright future
ahead of them so alright so far pretty
pretty kind of boring opening so far
ninety-two play Bishop d6
maybe he'll play e4 maybe not him please
c4 I don't know how I want plays I'm
just gonna Castle I'll take I'm gonna
take on d5
so I'll take and in the meantime cluck
cluck clone pong clown and what's it
clone pond if you could just write your
name in the chat and I'll I'll challenge
you after after this game g3 I'm gonna
play I can play Bishop h3 put b6
interesting
Queenie 7 more stand or Age 5 I'm gonna
play h5 I'll play something unusual try
to make it interesting more interesting
better than usual there should be two on
a play age for trying week in this this
this king size pawn structure White's
pawns around around the King now I could
take I can play h3 I'm just gonna take
I'm gonna go like Bishop g4 maybe rook
e8 or Queen Queen e sovereign and we'll
see what he wants to do and in the
meantime G dog says not caring if you
know isolated pawn yeah an isolated pawn
is not the end of the world and in most
cases but it is one of the toughest
things to understand for fer amateur
players is how to play with with an
isolated pawn but here I have more than
enough compensation especially with the
slightly weakened King slide the white
hats the Bishop d2 I don't like we now 5
I want to swing this Queen to h5
attacking the knight obviously is to
choice you can go to like h4 d 4 maybe
h2 a little bit passive on h2 I expect
Knight h4 maybe or Knight d4 not really
sure
and meantime yeah so alright 294 I'm
gonna go queen h5 what's the next move
there should be four so try to exchange
the bishop so I'm gonna play work da so
when he exchange maybe maybe I can swing
my rope from d6 to h6 maybe create some
extra mate threats here you know like
along the h-file like if I can get 94
and work h6 I mean it's an absolute
dream so so let's let's just see what he
wants to do here hi Shiva writes was
that Chris Littlejohn yes it actually
was so moving on that was not Maurice
Ashley sorry sorry guys sorry to
disappoint you guys
so f3 push page 3 Queen C to C wants to
exchange bishops um I mean if I take
he's gonna take with the king so I'm
gonna play rook e8 put pressure on his a
pawn and maybe if he loses real call
this I'll just retreat the bishop maybe
not sure yet but I might I might do that
cuz yeah I I mean I don't I don't really
want to retreat the bishop but I feel
like if I exchanged there is some danger
that he could take with the King and
then he could maybe attack me on the H
file he gets like a rook each one with
anything going over there so he goes
King F - it's a strange move I'm gonna
play Queen g5 try to put pressure on
these pawns I mean he can go work h1 but
the knight on f6 covers h7
so I will so we'll see what he wants to
do here you play so he goes Queen c7 I'm
gonna play rook d6 attack the pawn on b2
b3 on a play like rook a six I mean I'm
not I don't really have anything special
here I have to say but I don't play with
c8 clean out 426 plays rook h1 good move
no but actually rook h1 I play Knight g4
Knight e4 g4 takes takes g5 takes takes
recursive tonight five takes e5 both
ones look interesting but I don't see a
knock out so I'm just gonna play Knight
eh7 and and try to stay solid here so
Queen h4 play broke up six now for now
I'm gonna go Bishop g4 Bishop f3 I'll
take probably if you lose the rook you
guys rookie to not a lot of options here
I'm just gonna play rook b8 though
tonight f3 I can I could take I don't
have I don't really want to take I gonna
play rook e8 here but now that I just
lie Knight g5 maybe not I can play still
play Queen g5 and somehow survive but
this is not really what I want to do I
mean because no no again I'm gonna be a
slip to flag and then this was not I
mean I don't mind flagging people but
this isn't really what I wanted to do so
wish me h3 now if I take okay so he's
threatening takes out five so
Bishop e4 seems logical my h7 I'll take
I'll take and now I take
before I mean okay positions even but
position remains very even of course but
but I mean he's got no time here so and
now if i if I'm able to run my King in
with like King G for work see - this is
gonna get really bad for ye just now but
now my Kings coming in to f3 and now
it's all over
so that was an ideal for him I'll play
d4
what's a Knight f3 the III let's please
c4 in something maybe Bishop e2
something random something unusual
and in the meantime I'll play d5 gonna
castle probably six 9300 KJ click JK
clarinet so that literally I'm sorry I
didn't I didn't see the chat clone clone
pond so yeah you're up next after this
game the 90 to 97
efore and again thank you for the
donation JK clarinet play Ricky one
let's see which which move white wants
or black wants to play here
so a six I'm gonna go a four or B eight
no I think I'll repeat I'm gonna play a
five and basically I'd really like to
get a night's like c4 and b6 if I can
doesn't look like it quite works here so
I'm just gonna play like you know what
I'm gonna do I can play nicely for put
each three maybe I'm gonna play off
through though just protect the pawn on
on protect the pawn on e4 9594 probably
helped take to go 94 as well Knight h5
is also a possibility tonight eh so I'm
just gonna take on b5 and play the very
ultra aggressive g4
so it takes on c4 so I can take on each
five but no this take on c4 Knight f6 no
I'm gonna play I think I'll just play g5
probably 97 now for it's a bit of a
double-edged position maybe Bishop b4
shot or Queen c7 now I'm gonna play
rookie tooks I want to get the rook off
this long diagonal I want to maybe play
b3 2 so I'm gonna go b3 and now I can
swing the rope over as well although
actually I just realized after rook e8
if I play rookie - I hang the pawn on e5
so I could be a slight issue but we'll
see anyway we'll see so what's his next
move gonna be
so all right let's see
and all right mid mid midnight Fox dota
donated $5 as well thank thank you
thanks for donation again I don't know
why it's not I really don't know why
nothing's showing up and I'm in the on
the screen but I'll sort out before the
next one so all right so I've to two of
you guys up in the queue after this game
now I don't know is he lagging is he
just deep in the tank what's going on
exactly
and Borko says will knock a break 3,000
Jay no that's not gonna happen tonight
if you know when I want to go for 3,000
it's gonna require a lot more time first
of all and it's gonna require me being
extremely serious and not playing for
the fans so much and right now I kind of
would rather just enjoy myself and play
for the fans
so night f8 I'm gonna play b4 try to
take advantage of this Bishop here on d4
he goes Queen c8 I'm gonna play h3 stop
Queen Jew 497 I'm gonna go b5 f5 Wow
f5 unfortunately think it's a little bit
too late now I think I can play e5 and
now he's probably will take on b5 but ok
King e7 King g7 hopefully 6 now I
resigned
okay so oh okay so Jake a clarinet is
first up actually did you want what kind
of game to Jake and Clara not want three
oh yeah three oh okay all right
challenge is on its way
so efore I'll play Sicilian I have three
d6 d4 I'll take play Knight f6 probably
a6 playing I adore FC what he wants to
which lining is prepared Richard III Oh
someone's trying to play like play like
I play my actual plays against a mdl in
the Norwich have Simone about two months
ago so g6 Bishop g7 I'm VL didn't play
g6 with this another setup that is well
known and I think also there was a
scheme an Illuminati giri in this line
as well so it's so 96 in fact I think
we're following that game quite possibly
so takes maybe like I think Kanako
played like Queen e1 Queen h4 if I
remember correctly
so bjh rights naka plays more like a mon
less like hanson I don't know what that
means does that mean so I mean is that a
good thing or a bad thing
I don't know so be through that's a
strange way I'm gonna play Knight you
for 1994 maybe as well but 994 play 493
I've Queen b6 Chuck this knight on c3 is
on pre feels a little bit too loose here
for ye
cesspit writes I'm having Greek chicken
with Satsuki baked potatoes and green
salad it sounds very good having been
here in acid now for Athens now for a
couple of days I mean Greek food is just
it's amazing stuff I mean pretty much
everything it's just out of this world
and I think anyone who has the chance
should definitely come here take a
vacation
see ya and see the Parthenon all the
Acropolis and you know go to some of the
islands it's just a just a great place
so queenie 1 so it protects the night
now I have no tricks here on f2 good
move umm very good move actually very
good move I'm gonna do something weird
I'm gonna play h5 I don't know if this
is a good move or bad move but I'm gonna
try and do something a little bit
strange
so each three this is actualize hoping
you would do nominees how do I take
advantage of this I'm gonna play like
Queen eight five probably hopefully a
Bishop b2 maybe Bishop d2 I'm not sure
which Square is going to it goes to d2
so I'm gonna play Bishop d7 this might
be a blunder but I don't see a it
doesn't look like it's losing outright
or on the spot so I'm gonna play it
anyway so now includes the HP four so he
does bite I'm gonna check them on d4 now
I don't know if this works or not but
so he goes work f2 I'm gonna take on g4
try to swing this Queen over and check
meet him on each one
I'm also threatening g3 potentially
place Knight a for now go Queen h5 I
guess he's still surviving somehow king
of one just barely
maybe the rook h1 was stronger actually
rotation one probably was winning rook
h1 takes Queen striking joint G through
is probably probably winning I think but
I'm not I'm not certain this somehow is
winning but it's not clean although I
can just grab the rook I guess I mean
guess I'll just grab the rug
it's a g3 I think I'll play Bishop d4
now
Keeney - I'm gonna grab a second second
exchange try to exchange the Queens
killer cat sent a donation says hey
Hikaru great stream thank you very much
for the donation killer cat killer cats
that's a cool nickname I like that
all those cats is that supposed to be
Kasim as in Kazim Ghulam Ali or is that
just completely random
all right so Bishop d3 all player okay
to not be three is week basically
everything just kind of kind of loose
here for white so all all just important
not to take a Forex on the review Bishop
c6 checked King e4 feels like there
should be a meet here somehow I don't
see it right off but I'm gonna try to
find a way to meet him like I don't know
rook t1 maybe play for f5 but he doesn't
have enough time so kind of irrelevant
so alright so let's see where's Kappa so
[Music]
so midnight Fox DotA said okay okay got
it got it
sorry so I had the wrong wrong wrong
wrong nickname okay alright so
all right so challenge has been sent and
challenge is not been accepted so maybe
he wants to challenge me maybe just
challenge me midnight daughter since for
whatever reason it seems like it's
challenge isn't going through because
your says your formulize does not match
members current settings so maybe
challenge me directly that that might be
a simpler way it's possible I don't know
if someone can configure that out so
pennilyn says Shan Muruga I don't know
who sham Muruga is passing them people
are passing the credit card alright okay
so did he challenge me midnight Fox
midnight Fox I don't see him oh there it
is there it is okay there it is whoops
whoops whoops what's wrong one wrong one
wrong one just click click the wrong one
so sorry about that
umm yeah well let me let me midnight
there it is yeah and voila
alright and we're off so d4 I'll play
Knight f6 Knight r3 I'm gonna go grab
some water give me a second
Seymour Olivia should be for Chuck so
Bishop d2 what I do hope lacy five
something a little bit unusual different
pawn structure will be happening
III I'll castle Bishop d3 d6 castles
knight c6 so far relatively normal I
mean a little bit unusual but not no not
that not that unusual so Rick you want
I'm gonna play e5 play something
something different
Leonardi row 0 made a donation of $10
Thank You Lane art for the for the
donation Queen d2 I completely forward
here I think I will I mean it's not
necessarily the best move 97 is much
more standard but I want to I want to
try and try and meet this guy quickly
with this King here on Julian's pawn on
G - I mean this King is very open
potentially probably bish buff one
Bishop g2 would make sense to try and
help this king or you can swing the King
over but then there might be 95 so there
should be 2 on to play Queen h4 try just
hunting d6 which was not very good not
very smart with me who is king h1 I'm
gonna play like Queen h6 I guess and I
forgot that I was hanging this pawn on
d6 fact I'm actions in trouble here
White's white significantly better but
the game game continues
it's a 95 or it's a good move Knight g6
so now he does take the pawn on to you
so I'll play Bishop a5 tried he creates
and play over here hopefully I mean this
is this is not very very good but um but
one can hope so I've got myself into a
very bad position here in this this game
I'm gonna need to and gonna need some
errors from my opponent to probably get
back into it so I'm gonna play g6
protect the bishop here on f5
okay should you want to play King entry
get out of any any stuff on this G file
here before now I think I'm gonna play
off six three three Bishop e6
and now he's taking quite a bit of time
so I'll play rocky eight
so what's with the deep tanks here so
it's really going deep into the tank so
I'll take the pond probably take steaks
trust bees 51 rights I really hope naka
loses um good to know good to know of
course good to know so it's a rook d3
I'm gonna play Bishop c8 maybe do
something along this ah-1 diagonal if I
get the opportunity so I'm gonna play I
play like Roachy offering exchange and
then maybe this King becomes really weak
on on h1 rook to d1 and I could play
Knight d4 maybe no it's not not any good
so I'll play where cafe 95 now I think
here I can take and play 94 maybe yeah I
think 94 now he's got problems here I'm
in big problems so
so yeah so says Chuck stream Labs
alright
penguin GM wants us please play me on
chess calm and that ik panda says for a
game
okay so vadik is gonna get first dibs on
that and then penguins gonna get get a
game as well DISA Queen c7 Knight takes
off three and I think is this checkmate
or not it doesn't I don't know if it is
alright yeah actually I came to to just
Knight age four and it's Chuck made as
the bishop covers h3 so all right so
that ik panda if you can remind me what
your what your name is vadik Panda
okay so killer cats okay so who okay one
second Oh so so so penguin doesn't want
to play me he wants to play it Muruga
okay so um so okay so so so so vatic
remind me what your what your what your
name is on chess talk on eros oh no my
battery super low once I need you guys
alright there we go much better much
better okay okay so okay so panda master
then killer cos penguin master 2,700
so okay where's killer Cass in the
meantime pant or sari panda master not
penguin master what am I thinking
panda master there can only be one one
penguin master
so panda master I'm not seeing Canada
master
whereas panda master my just blind
somehow meanwhile see in other news
narrow did see a shot of it looks like
he wants to play me too
but you guys come first so let's see
where his panda master not seeing panda
master maybe he could challenge me nuts
are there he is okay so I'll play panda
master there we go
panda master good luck to e4 please see
five
tonight our 3d6 probably d4 I'll take
all right have six probably 93 I'll play
another night or I'll make a pre movie 5
everyone's playing this Bishop d3
against me tonight for some reason I
don't know why Knight d2 everyone I
guess everyone feels like playing like
knock more for some reason I don't know
why but I'll play G something something
unusual something different see what he
wants to do
castles Bishop g7 pretty standard so far
a forum on a castle played Bishop e6
next maybe knight c6 I don't know I'm
gonna put the night on e6 c6 or d7 one
of the two haven't decided yet I think
it depends with this a4 movement makes
more sense because now there's this be
Foursquare to go knight c6 Knight before
now please f4 yeah now I'm gonna go
knight c6 for sure now five now I'm
gonna take probably he'll take maybe not
he has Bishop g5 also but Bishop g5
about four probably originally v eh6 so
it takes d5 now it's got to be careful
because now play E for probably Bishop
e2
I'm gonna go III if he takes then I have
d4 with the fork on both both the bishop
and the night if he doesn't I mean I'm
probably going d4 no matter what he
plays in fact
so it's okay so I'm not you guys the
chats gotten interesting I trying to
focus on playing this game here but chat
definitely has gotten very very
interesting so d 494 I mean I can take
I'm gonna go I think I think I'm gonna
go 95 now 95 probably he'll take I'll
take
it's officially four and play like
rookie eight maybe is one move Bishop d7
is also going to try and force some
exchanges here in the center of the
board I don't know if Bishop d7 is a
good move as I allowed to see three but
and still rather unclear so he takes
I'll take on B to probably work b1 maybe
work be one night C for this Bishop here
is very important as it stops away from
really creating any mating threats
probably I assume he'll go Bishop h6
it's a very natural looking move I think
I'm gonna play but I don't put on put on
them actually I am in some trouble here
if I'm not careful so Bishop six Queens
you for King h8 why not let's see what
he has here
- Queen j48 he takes on that fade I'll
go Chuck Bishop c6 was it was a good try
but now I've queen d4 and in between
mouths and now takes takes king each one
takes now Bishop f8 rook f8 and now
something this pawn of b2 is really
dukes up about 83 and d2 I'll go too
I don't have actually I could play just
c5 but night a3 looks correct so he's
gonna have to take on d4 90 xbone
probably work before roof d8 now he's
gonna go h4i so ah he goes King g1 so
now how to play this so if I check and
then I check them on D to change it when
I think Knight c3 should be winning all
right Chuck Chuck Chuck checking do some
checking 6g for B 1 F 6 B 1 so all roads
lead to Rome
okay so next up is killer Kaz
Killer casts killer casts ok killer cows
2100 super strong player all right or
actually challenged did not go through
again so I don't know why it says
challenge does not match the members
current settings I know I don't know why
that is something it seems like that's
happening a lot lately so if you could
challenge me actually directly show cats
killer them that would that would that
would be helpful so I'm just gonna play
Shannon murugesan's
I guess if I'm and donated for him I
don't know if he did I'm gonna play some
anti anti anti computer trust let's see
what he does
[Music]
five up lychee for now probably night g3
next age six night g37 I'll play c4 c4
I'm just gonna play Queen e2 give it an
exchange on g2 if you want it me 26.93
so he takes I'm just gonna take with the
night plays rookie I'm gonna take on d4
probably he'll take with the e pawn now
I'm gonna go b4 try to expand here on
the con the Queen side 95 will take
labor kb1 try to use this open B file
it's gonna open up shortly so I'll take
gonna play Bishop c1 because because now
I've got this whole open P fun now I'm
not gonna play put rook beat with arrows
because that might actually turn into an
axe don't promote not would not that
would not end very well but here I
control the B file completely so 97 I
play a force of egos Knight b6 I have a
5 so he can't cut me off here on he
can't cut the B file 5 I'll take I could
play Bishop f4 here I don't know if I
will work a7 looks pretty route b7 sorry
it looks pretty good
f4 Bishop f4 both possible I just feel
like rook be something makes a little
bit more sons here Knight f6 now here I
could take and take but I think I want
to play rook e1 try to keep trying to
keep this this B file o open as much as
much as I can and now f5 is very weak
and he can't push up for so there are
some significant issues here for black
so he plays 98 so now I'm gonna go in
for the kill with Knight f5 rookie to
Bishop a4 for example which looks pretty
good I mean now with this B file
completely open this this looks very
very good for me tonight h4 it's
probably no king of six probably I'll
play rook
b7
hey five no no I'm gonna check him force
the King back I guess he can play rookie
six but I Knight a5 Bishop outfit now
I'm just gonna play Bishop take aged six
takes probably King g7 or kinky seven
I'm gonna check them again and no I
think it's time for this time for Harry
to run right up the board dhaa it's a
rookie five I'm gonna play Knight g3 and
go h5 just know I can just exchange cuz
I mean I've got this each point is
protected very nicely and now I just
bring my king up closer to let me see
seven I'll play trip to six got five
I'll play a king e4 or did I just
accidentally hang off to King D five
work a fifteen and six and whatever just
worked you five with the idea of work
age five if I get if I get this work age
five then he's uh
then he's thinnies toast so I'll take c5
I'm checking on b5 take this and now
it's just completely winning now it's
just a matter of technique let's see
five
at 44 now just the pawns roll right up
the board very nicely can see for be $1
play Brooke be six for six change no now
my king I can actually even run for the
a pawn but just King e6 and now he can't
stop it for cleaning the pond
and it's not selling because there's the
a pond on the board so it's just Chuck
made in one not smooth
so anyway moving right along
I'm not I'm not really sure what's going
on but anyway
looks like checkmated won I don't know I
mean maybe he's just gonna run out of
time here so no it looks like killer
casts if you could challenge me that
would be the simplest way for us to play
since I think isn't right now it's not
letting me challenge you
so anyway okay so killer calves let's
see can i maybe challenge you now no
it's not going through so hmm why is it
not going through
why is my challenge not going through
the killer casts hmm well that's
unfortunate
so it says killer cows it's not going
through
um okay maybe I'll maybe let me see if I
can maybe just challenge you unrated
maybe let's let's just see how if that's
possible maybe
unrated let's let's try that killer cows
let's see did that go through no their
challenge does not match numbers current
settings so I know if you guys in the
chat could maybe help out killer caste
and maybe it's a rating thing maybe that
maybe it's auto-set that the rate
maximum rating is lower than my current
rating I don't know maybe something like
that maybe if you guys could help them
out here on the chat since I can't seem
to
so yeah I can't I don't actually can't
figure out why it just keep saying I
can't challenge you so anyway in the
meantime while I wait
well I wait let's see who is there
anyone else online we sent out some
challenges in the meantime by no leus
maybe
so yeah you guys just let me know once
again if there is something going on I
mean uh just just let me know because I
I can't seem to figure out why I can't
challenge killer calves I mean maybe
something in the settings I'm not sure
what's going on
[Music]
so yeah let's see okay so is there
anyone else interested so Daniels
playing right now so whose is Buju knock
26:39 boot or brooch inna brucha not
with a Chuck fly interesting okay this
should be interesting let's see whose
brooch anak hi a pretty high rating
Chuck guy not many checks that that but
it could be I mean I guess it could be
like it could be Navarro it could be
last niche cut maybe hurrah check no not
not many not many possibilities there
there aren't that many top chuck players
so should be interesting to see 92 I'm
gonna play d5 takes hopefully Queen d5 I
don't know if it's if it's right but
maybe try to do something along this
long diagonal should be interesting so
play Knight f6 now if you councils I
don't know if I want to take or not I
mean I'm not really sure what I'm doing
here but I'll take since he played f3
I'm just gonna take on c3 play Knight
bTW 7 C for Queen b6 Oh oopsie this
Bishop f4 I just completely blundered
that not good not good but takes takes
still looks reasonably ok though
especially g3 I'm gonna castle and we'll
see what he wants to do here so in the
meantime
so if someone says this voltage plaque
plot I don't actually know who that is
strangely enough I don't think I've
heard that name before
I don't know hopefully Ricky eight okay
do you wanna go Queenie seven rookie one
good move maybe e4 here or just c5 I
mean I think I'll just play c5 d5 and
I'll play like I think I'm gonna go
Knight a fate
Mushmouth to see wants put a night on g3
that much is evident so I can go a night
g6n he3 night eh 493 tonight up for or
just something like night h5 in fact I
like nice righteous cousin ihe three
night f4
Wow g4 Wow aggressive 93 now I'm gonna
play Knight g6 does now he's got this
off Foursquare that's very loose I have
five play Queen d7 I can like you know
eight I'm gonna go clean up a mission
feed three I'm gonna play Bishop c8 who
he offers a draw what was that for I'm
gonna play Knight a for now
so probably he'll take but I'm not sure
probably is the key word here so takes
takes maybe because if he takes and I
get upon Dow 4 then I'm threatening g6
like if I get this pawn here because I'm
the knight relative to the pawn will
become quite weeks of g6 please fish by
4 1 so I can play g6
I mean g6 is interesting I don't know if
I love it but I'll go for why not
93 now I'm gonna play h5 force them to
clarify the situation over here on the
kingside by night h7 I mean I really
want to go like f6 probably he'll take
or no he won't take it please Queen eh -
I wanna play f6
so tix is gonna take I'll take takes
maybe I'll take with the king actually
yeah I don't know if taking with the
rook was better but I'm gonna take with
the king and I probably thinking that
the rook was was about her choice they
would have lost after I know after he's
stolen it's still in play but try and
get a knight to one of these two squares
ePHI d6 because now his pawn is passed
pawns block he had and c4 is week three
out that rookie seven I'm gonna double
the rooks and now whites whites in a lot
of trouble here
so rookie - hopefully bish face six
actually face this was a bad news
I just gave him work - one yeah
basics was not a good move but and
because somehow things always seem to
work out and still still doing quite
well because rook g6 Bishop fish cake c4
is pretty good now I mean this is better
than I deserve considering that I'm that
I basically blundered but it's all
turning out really really nicely no I'll
take King g3 I'm gonna play rook EE for
said if he takes a night I have h4 Chuck
so you take the bishop I go each one
that I take his rook and now after check
and now I just pick up the rook so he
has some with the King so the rooks free
the rook is not attacked anymore than I
just pick up the rook d6 can I just take
this night looks like it looks like a
free night work III I'm just like King
King e7 and I'm just completely winning
so it's an interesting interesting first
game play b3
probably this would be 2 next d65 okay
so this guy studies in theory it looks
like I have six hope lady for probably
four maybe he'll take yeah it takes nine
to four probably g6 I would assume 95
interesting that's interesting 95 will
place c4 okay Bishop e2 93 c6 castles
just finish development first on Queen
c7 I'm gonna play Queen c2 probably work
c1 work d1 and figure it out from there
I shall play H they first take with g4
and I don't know let's see what do you
want or d1 e1 one of the two but I think
I think I'll go for d1 81 so if I'm
gonna play trophy one there should be
seven I could play f4 hmm not my dealing
with Sona play Bishop f4 and just
retreat and figure it out later base
let's know I'll go for and me probably
I'll play g3 Bishop g2 if I get the
opportunity if I don't done so be it
but he's really asked me to go for it so
I don't really have a choice I'm gotta
try and push him back
so now maybe he plays h5 maybe it's
always a possibility d5 is the classic
way of trying to break it up but I think
here it doesn't quite work okay but he's
gonna go for it anyway so now the
question is here 45 I think I'm gonna
play e5 94 5 he can take c4 takes takes
take stroke d4 Knight b5 cb5 visual d4
so I could take a nun play but III don't
see any reason to avoid this so I play
e5 Knight 5 now I might take yeah I
think I'm going to take because when he
takes on g3 I'm gonna go d6
I mean queen f2 is also a possibility I
mean maybe I'll pre move these okay he
does just take back so I'm gonna go
Queen off to protect the pawns protect
this big pawn chain here and these
Knights are a little bit uncomfortable
to like h5 especially because maybe I
can go Bishop e2 an attack or go Queen
f3 also maybe a lot a lot of options
here these Knights are very
uncomfortable at any rate it's a Bishop
c5 standard standard move now Bishop e2
I assume he's in trouble ice I don't see
it so I'm gonna go for it there's b2 I
don't actually see why this doesn't just
pick up a piece okay so vetting panda
makes a donation of $5 let's play Muruga
again okay I'll I'll think about that
huh I thought I thought I just played
him once but okay so I still waiting on
killer calves of course still waiting on
him so we'll see but he you know if he
figures out his settings so that we can
we can play and I takes off for I'll
take probably Bishop takes h3 I would
assume oh so he's trying to set up
something here I mean I'm gonna go
teenage to try to push the bishop away
you know I'm gonna go like night a4 and
probably Bishop a7 I'm gonna play like
Queen g3 or something
so now I'm trying now after 20 turning
night b5 the Queen may be i-5 at some
moment protect making sure there no sax
here either very important no no play
work see one pushes Queen further back
night c5 and now like all basically is
happening those blacks just losing
ground everywhere and black is down a
piece here for a couple of pawn so he
needs to try and create some counter
play and it's just not not really
happening here
so f6 now e6 is possible then e six
looks pretty strong takes f5 and I think
I mean this just looks winning but I
think I'm just picking up a second piece
here basically I found qui nice up clean
87 but that doesn't actually change the
situation does it so I can just move my
rock you know I'll just take the bishop
and now there are no no discoveries
anywhere here so I'm just up to clean
pieces so alright so I guess I guess
I'll play Sheeran Muruga again let's see
if he's still here still I have to not
forget about killer calves as well so
killer calves is still still still
waiting to play killer calves all right
so let's see its own place Shannon
Muruga pretty standard hippo set up
quite a bit and it looks like he's
playing the same exact same stuff that
is playing the previous game except he's
a plant plan was here with with white so
III I'm gonna play I can play f5 I'll
play off five and he goes h3 so I'm
gonna play rock b8 just to prevent any
Knight g5 nonsense like g5 now h4 play
Knight g6 see if he wants to take so he
does take g5 I can go g4 now or even a
five this is looking pretty good
so let's see so g4 I mean II five
suppose it looks correct you for snow I
could play g4 here maybe so now yeah I
think g4 though when he moves deny to go
off f4 as well so this looks really
really bad for white
so f3 I take if you take C got to meet
it in one
okay that was strange
okay so in the meantime where is um
biller cast killer casts
so killer casts let's see
are you still still around killer okay I
see 1800 but now I see 1800 maybe now
it's maybe now it works Oh what's going
on your challenge is not matching the
numbers current settings what what is
going on here
what is going on here okay so I I don't
I don't get this I mean this doesn't
make any sense
um this is annoying
so killer Kaz what's the problem what is
the problem here what is the problem
maybe I can challenge them unrated I
mean this is ridiculous
[Music]
ciao unrated I don't know maybe he can
try challenging me I keep getting the
year challenges not match the members
current settings is something is it
something it's got to be something that
the rating settings I don't let me see
so so I'm guessing it's in settings
[Music]
probably settings bottom left-hand
corner I where I'm highlighting and you
can probably change the maximum rating I
guess let me if you're watching this
color cause I think probably here this
fourth button this rating range probably
just changes these two to arrow or
whatever these would is what is that
symbol I forgot what it is but just
change it to these two symbols and then
probably we can play I assume you just
saw that so probably that's what you
need to do I think that's what you need
to do is just change change of settings
right there and then I think we can play
I think that's got to be what it is cuz
I don't know what else it could be yeah
I don't know what also could be so let's
see
[Music]
it's just not working okay fair enough
so all right I guess in the meantime
let's see who else is here so Daniels
here Sergei chess is here maybe I'll
play Sergei chassis is pretty serious
serious guy also played him in the blitz
blitz challenge as well so if he wants
to play I guess yeah now some of my
challenges aren't aren't working for
anyone so I don't know what's going on
Michael q2 d5 maybe you want to play I
guess not
[Music]
so yeah let's see okay
Seau let's see alright so um in the
meantime let's see so so what else what
else am I missing right now not seeing
the child I'm not seeing killer casts
this is really annoying but anyway okay
so Sergei my challenge isn't going
through to Michael's q2d v is playing
maybe I'll play penguin a couple of
games maybe that's always an option if
he wants to play so yeah okay so it's
penguin time here we go
rock and roll okay III I'm gonna play
something well let's just see what
penguin wants to play tonight I'm gonna
play some different stuffs of b3 there
should be - okay like Knight f3 I guess
d4
let's see what he wants to do so alright
it's penguin time knight c6 actually
isn't that supposed to be it's hammer
time that's actually the croc phrase
there should be three but should be six
I'm gonna I I'm gonna play Knight d2
I'll just play something strangely
normal yeah I mean I guess I'll take
I'll take and play eith Rin will play
something original I shall say it should
be seven I'll play queenie to probably
put the rooks d1c one play for b4 c4 or
e for I mean basically these are the
three key squares and put it ropes on C
one D you want something like that I
mean make some no sons objectively
so let's see okay so see what his next
move is gonna be is penguin am i lagging
is penguin lagging something going on
as penguin laughing or I mean I don't
know what's been really slow basically
okay so I wanna play Eve for try to open
up the center as fast as I can
please rook c8 and I'm gonna play play
rock 81 basically try and do something
along this deep file now cuz Queen c7
now that's that's strange
no I can play e5 I can place c4 I mean
there are a lot of different options I'm
gonna play c4 if you take tell this by
night c4 clean out for what is queen up
for doing play b4 kick this Bishop off
this diagonal fish about fate now I can
play g3 if I want I think I will play
cheats or in fact some time I don't
really understand what penguin is doing
here so Queen Queen age 695 is possible
93 maybe King G - I mean h4 a lot of
different options but I think here I'm
just gonna take on f6 and play e5 and do
something in the center so place GF 6
and I go eat 5
that's like four anymore
like Fe night-night Fe 5 o Kay place
rook d8 so I can take on off 6 if I want
and I think I do want to take on f6
there should be 4 planets long diagonal
so we'll see what he wants to do here
submission fee for see what do you what
he wants to play so h6
now I've b5 gonna just be 5 95 95 I know
it's the only move but make something
sense or I can just take on B sobbing
but I think I'm just gonna take on 85
and take on e4 play like I can play if
I'm just gonna play a for Bishop c5 can
g2
tulsi I mean like King g7 now I've kind
of manage to miss play this slightly
time you know I've let him off the hook
a little bit like I'm gonna go Brooks
before try to put something along this
fourth-ranked maybe like Queen e2 and
rook G for work f4 rook got Flo Rida
wavin whoa Queen g6 95 know what does
queen g6
that's yeah that was not not not a good
try it's alright let's see so is Dan
Daniel actually online now I can't tell
if he is I think he is so I'm gonna play
him let's see wants to go
I'm just gonna play something unusual
this game there should be seven maybe
take stakes see Knight f3 okay so I'll
play Bishop c6 a little bit confusing
what exactly is this line like oh did I
just blunder something - yeah I think I
just wandered something yeah I just
realized as soon as I played it that i
blundered it but anyway let's say so
Bishop g2 so he's gonna have to take my
Queen now I can take the rook or the
bishop but neither one is really very
very good here but I think I'll I'll
take the rook miss b5 we'll play like
knight c6 and and hope like this is this
is really just terrible
I guess he's thinking here I don't know
is he not so you just castles okay now
that's interesting so I'm just gonna
take something like 97 I guess I mean if
I can get castles I'm doing fine
d5 I can probably just castle so I'm
probably doing okay here not great but
probably not not lost which is really
all that matters because considering
that I hung my queen I mean this so you
place c6 I guess and d5 I mean or will
he
I think I should just castle can't my
king out of the center just got it get
to a position and just play chess and
actually had Queen h5 there which would
have been pretty bad for me but don't
play f5 rough three now go like then go
play Knight b6 now this is turning out
reasonably well it's still much worse
for me obviously I mean I'm missing
missing a queen but it could be a lot
lot worse
it's or if d3 I'm just gonna play like I
don't play rook g8 maybe try to force me
to like play be three or something to
create some weaknesses in his position
so he does go b3 all chuck go Bishop g7
and now it's it's it's improved it's
improved quite a bit now but it's still
a long way to go before I'm back to a
position that I should be happy with
totally bish five six I mean I should
have played rook f1 but not a big deal
it's a queen bee force who wants to go a
four he wants to go a four and something
like that I mean so if I give him if you
got the a4 a5 I'm in real trouble so
probably rook work f1 or T to e5 maybe
that could be a try so why not
and rookie - I also Bishop g5 but I'm
gonna go a five here because basically
if I can get this diagonal closed then
the bishop has no scope along this
diagonal and maybe I'm also threatening
to just take on d4 - so it's it's not so
simple here
so queen b5 now I can take on d4 maybe
or I can just move my rook rook e1 looks
like a try work e1 take 684 or takes
takes maybe I just take and take on f2
yeah maybe I just take unless I'm
missing something obvious here which I
don't think I am so takes I can play
rook f2 or Bishop d4 King King was rook
takes off to boat both both ways worth I
think I probably should just take on d4
though and work do for work f2 and I
think I'm flying take 6 Queenie ain't
night CA yeah and King c2 maybe I have
rotate one also
so yeah I'm gonna go for okay one now
and rook d4 takes Queen he ain't Knight
CA so takes ro k - Kim D one and yeah I
mean maybe we tried something better but
I'm not seeing it so I could just check
I guess which I think I'll do thrown at
shock and that was bad that was a bad
bad idea no no no no I'm in trouble cuz
I kind of miss played this so what to do
I'm gonna go 85 I'm gonna just basically
go all in here oh and I just wonder
Queenie for terrible that's not gonna
get it done but actually wait do I have
some tricks here maybe I stole some
tricks in this position
because I sell some tricks here maybe
it's officially for alright this would
be for visually for I mean I probably
don't it's gonna play ninety-six and try
to hold this somehow I mean
and what's going on
I can't really tell I mean it's my
lagging is he lagging and there we go
there we go
and it should just be winning now and
maybe not though I've kind of again I've
kind of
what is going on is that lag really
really hmm that was very strange all
right you guys well I guess I'm probably
gonna stop for the night then I think I
don't know what that was that was like
ridiculous cuz I was just like that was
strange I guess it was just like on my
end I mean I was very weak he was like
and then I was like and then someone was
lagging but that was weird um that was
very weird anyway fair enough all right
you guys so I think I'm gonna start for
the night it's getting pretty late here
so yeah so I guess I will yeah I mean I
guess I'll catch with everyone after the
World Cup but yeah for now I mean that's
that's gonna be all until until until
after the World Cup which hopefully I do
quite well hopefully I make it all the
way but at any rate I hope you guys have
enjoyed the stream and until next time
have a good evening I guess it should be
pretty early back in the u.s. so have a
good evening and I'll catch up with
everyone um next time so good night